I was born into a homeless family and
and I grew up in the slums of San
Francisco I mean I've been on probation
since my missionary date since eighth
grade the first done I never had pointed
in my head it was when I was 12 years
old by a police officer typical story
you could say that's the first time I
guess I was perceived as a problem I got
involved I got caught up in the system
then they sent me to group homes and
rested me again I spent 90% of my
teenage life in juvenile hall
and the juvenile system makes you know
I'm 17 going on 18 I'm still on these
guys didn't ever let me be free and
everything but not any little thing oh
you miss feeling luckier and that's
where the school to Prison Pipeline
starts
so the care program is Center for
academically entering the town here and
basically there are two C program in a
formula school
youth are disconnected from their school
they end up in the streets and they end
up in harm's way and then ultimately
they end up in prison or dead we
addressed the behavior we peel back the
layers and oftentimes we discover it's
it's learned it's trauma it's things
that have happened in the community how
I first got under probation was an
incident with a teacher edge was
Washington High School he was both in
the hallways I was bouncing my ball and
he said I hit him I did not hit that
teacher after I got arrested for
something I didn't do
my whole mindset of the systems I want
nothing to do with it you guys are
something else
you guys set people up for failure you
but as I go back and now recollect I
could've easily got taken to the
principal's office instead of having me
carried out in the back of a police car
when I finally came back here and came
to my senses they helped me look for
jobs we provide services for them to
find their self-worth in and become
self-sufficient I hear a lot of kids
always say things like well you guys
actually care about us you guys actually
have our bank most kids are stomped on
and crushed early it's very difficult to
to transition to turn your life around
and that's why we have this program
you